carnegie mellon university has partnered
with the tony awards for the second
annual excellence and theatre education
award so i went to a very small private
school shorecrest prep in st. Petersburg
Florida only a couple hundred people in
my high school everybody knew everybody
and it was and we became active in
thespians my sophomore year between my
parents and a couple of my teachers Leo
lean who was one of my high school drama
teachers my aunt Ginny strainer was also
one of my drama teachers they fostered
this desire to not only follow your
dreams but that this was a viable career
and you should treat it like a career
and I've always been so passionate about
theatre education because i always use
this analogy if you want to be a doctor
you don't just go hang out at a hospital
you have to do the work
you